[Music]
welcome aboard TV lovers I'm your host
and captain Leon Aguilera and this is
ship worthy the only show devoted to
celebrating the most swoon worthy
couples on TV I'm particularly thrilled
with today's pairing because this is our
very first flashback episode of ship
worthy and I'm gonna be tugging on your
nostalgia and loving heartstrings
because we're talking all about Cory
Matthews and Topanga Lawrence from Boy
Meets World I love you I will always
it's been 25 years since Cory and
Topanga first locked lips and I'm
bringing you a brand new interview with
actor Ben savage spilling
behind-the-scenes secrets from that
iconic kiss that was my first ever TV
kiss yes and I was very nervous now
here's a little captain's confession for
you Cory and Topanga was the very first
couple I've ever shipped they were
relationship goals before I even knew
what that meant which means they hold a
very special place in this 90s girl's
heart so let's take a look back at how
this lifelong couple first sailed onto
our screen way Cory and Topanga have
known each other their entire lives
he was the sports-loving slacker who was
just trying to fit in and she was the
quirky yet confident girl who danced to
the beat of her own interpretive drum
donut in the sky
you actually try to be weird I don't
think I'm weird
I think I'm unique there were a few
years when they were preteens when Cory
actively tried to deny his crush on
Topanga I like to call those the Lost
years but his feelings for Miss Lawrence
were reignited with their first kiss
you shouldn't kiss somebody who not
married too yeah I would have to feel I
really knew the person and that I liked
him as the first season continued things
grew deeper and even cuter between these
two with their second smooch in season
two sparks were starting to fly and by
their third time locking lips Cory and
Topanga were feeling peachy keen with
their poetry night makeout sesh and then
everything changed in the season 3
premiere when Cory made girls everywhere
swoon when he has Topanga a very
important question Topanga
if I had to dream up the perfect woman
she wouldn't even come close to would
you be my girlfriend oh my goodness you
know Cory and Topanga take the term
highschool sweethearts to a whole other
level and now let's let this flashback
love fest continue in naughty or nice
normally at this time I like to break
down a couple's cutest and steamiest
moments together
but since Cory and Topanga have 7
seasons worth of cavity inducing
sweetness we're gonna skip the naughty
bits and focus solely on some of their
nicest scenes there are a lot that's
what I knew we were only 6 cameras in
addition to all the adorable scenes
we've already highlighted we definitely
need to talk about that time when
topanga's parents forced her to move to
Pittsburgh fans let out a full-on aw
when she ran away and showed up on
Corey's doorstep dripping wet from the
rain which led Cory to deep dive into a
heart-melting monologue about how he
can't live without her she was the girl
I set up every night thinking about and
I mean when I'm with her I feel happy to
be alive like I can do anything and
while it's true that Cory and Topanga
experienced some rough waters over the
course of 7 seasons
yep I'm looking at you Lauren this
twosome always triumphs and gave fans
some all the fields scenes in the
process during a brief break up in
season 3 Cory was determined to win
Topanga back so he followed her on a
trip to Disney World and pulled out all
of the magical stops luckily his plan
worked I'm really confused
what's going on you know are we friends
away
and viewers were treated to one of the
most epic kisses in TV history after the
lauren debacle of 1998 when Cory was
kissed by another girl the couple had a
lot of soul-searching to do to find out
if they could survive the betrayal this
is just a painting this is a masterpiece
we're a masterpiece and I don't care
what you think right now we're gonna be
together forever thanks to a lackluster
date and another kiss that meant nothing
Topanga had an epiphany about her
feelings for Cory I don't mean high
school I love you I love you too I mean
I am in love with Cory Matthews and I
wanna be there's nobody else in the
world for me and there never will be
I'm taken and while Cory and topanga's
wedding was a big milestone for the
small screen couple it was their
proposal in the season 5 finale that
made everyone's jaws dropped ladies and
gentlemen the John Adams high school
class of 1994 II and Topanga of course
went on to live a long and happy life
together and we got to see their lives
as parents in the can some too soon
series Girl Meets World but I'm dying to
know which other Boy Meets World scenes
were your favorite tell me in the
comments below now as I mentioned
earlier this year is the 25th
anniversary of Cory and topanga's first
kiss so when I recently caught up with
Ben savage at the 80 X Television
Festival I happily asked him all the
behind the scenes boy meets world
secrets take a look fans love for me
swirled so much who is the last cast
member that you texted danielle fishel
last night just to say hello Daniel
officially Topanga they know that right
of course they know that I was saying
hello and I was saying how much she was
making me laugh on Twitter yesterday
she's very funny I'm a damsel but not
the distressed kind when who's very
together and in complete control of her
own destiny one of the things that was
so great is that fans experience first
along with Cory and Topanga we at ET
recently just did a roundup of the most
iconic TV kisses and we
Cory and topanga's in there against the
locker against the locker was that your
first ever TV kiss that was my first
ever TV kiss yes and I was very nervous
because we did that scene in front of a
live audience
so I was 11 and I was 12 but I was
nervous I mean pretty girl
tons of people watching there's a locker
but it was it was fine
yeah and it was fine it was so sweet
that we buried you and Danielle were so
young at the time did you say no 11 and
I was 12
did you talk about it beforehand do you
remember any of that no I think we just
did it I don't think there's a lot of
like okay now we're very young yeah I
don't even think of the time we just
gave it that much thought in terms of
like the repercussions but Danielle's a
sweetheart and she was always a good
when I was 13 mums she put me up against
my locker
she kissed me I mean she gave me my
first kiss overall Cory and Topanga will
always have a special place in my heart
because this is a couple that I grew up
adoring they gave me hope that one day
I'd find a guy who is just as
unwaveringly passionate as Cory and
showed me that a relationship could be
equal parts silly and sweet perfect fit
yeah my guess and there you have it that
does it for our very first flashback
episode of schipper thee and if you had
fun sailing with me then please give
this video a like and then hit the
comments with your favorite Cory and
Topanga moments Plex if you have any
other ship suggestions for future
episodes of ship worthy tell me which
couple you think I should feature and
why you love them now until next time
bon voyage TV lovers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]